So in the, the previous two examples we were talking about the value of
an attribute and those are usually pretty straightforward. Let's now talk about
operations. OCL provides a way to specify operations using pre and
post-condition constraints. These are different keywords in the language.
In this case, we're going to look at requirement three, which describes some
query operations. Now by query operation, I mean an operation that is asking
about the value of an attribute, but not changing anything. So, in this case,
it should be straightforward to have an operation that returns that value.
So, the requirement itself says, in addition, at any particular point in time,
the library may need to know or to calculate. The items a patron has
checked out, when they are due and any outstanding overdue fines. So,
let's concentrate on a part about the items a patron has currently checked out.
So, previously when we did our analysis, we associated this text with
an operation class patron called items currently checked out.
What we need to do now is to say something about that particular operation.
We need to make it stated more precisely then just saying that it exists. And
in fact, we have to say that the value computed by this operation corresponds to
just those items that are checked out for that patron. Recall that we have a,
an association between patron and loanable item.
And that association is going to record what items are checked out.
And now we're talking about the operation in patrons, so
essentially that operation is querying the association, and
we want to make sure that what the operation returns is in fact,
what's appropriately expressed in the association.